nicolau lo es una de las figuras de la
causa medioambiental en francia pero
ahora seis mujeres incluida una menor de
edad en el momento de los hechos lo
acusan de violación y agresión sexual
entre ellas hay una empleada de un
importante canal de televisión una
actriz y una ex colega de trabajo todas
acusan a bulo de haberse aprovechado de
su cargo para abusar de ellas en su
momento antes de estos alegatos el
ecologista y ex presentador de
televisión anunció su retiro definitivo
de la vida pública luego de haber
mostrado su indignación donde es una
ilusión la justicia hoy bajo la presión
de los movimientos sociales o las
demandas muy legítimas de las mujeres
nos decimos bueno aunque se acabe el
tiempo y que no habrá juicio abramos el
caso de todos modos al inicio del
mandato de manuel macrón nicolau lo era
el ministro de ecología renunció después
de un año al estar en desacuerdo con
varias medidas ambientales tomadas
recibió el apoyo de sus colegas cuando
pascal mitigan nieta del ex presidente
de la república presentó una denuncia
por violación después de un tiempo él
fue cerrado y no se hizo seguimiento en
cuanto a las recientes acusaciones en su
contra la fiscalía de parís ha abierto
una investigación preliminar por
violación y agresión sexual por actos
que probablemente se hayan cometido en
parís con respecto a una víctima menor
de edad